[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo América
de France 24 Daniel hablandon ya está
con nosotros en el estudio Daniela Qué
bueno tenerla por acá hoy jueves ya casi
finalizamos esta semana informativa un
día nos queda freír a descansar y
Francia presentó su plan energético de
Cara a este invierno Bueno pues de Raúl
en declaraciones a empresarios en París
el presidente Emanuel macron adelantó
algunos por menores de este plan que lo
que busca es reducir el consumo para
evitar racionamientos en medio de toda
esta crisis energética generada por la
guerra en Ucrania y hasta le puso nombre
miren las objetiene
o sobriedad energética
de eso se trata la sobriedad de agilizar
los esfuerzos energéticos en este punto
necesitamos acelerar pequeñas
inversiones en términos de eficiencia
energética y tener algunos mecanismos
muy simples para lograr colectivamente
reducir en un 10% lo que solemos
consumir lo digo muy sencillo si toda la
nación logra cumplir con este objetivo
que es puramente voluntario No
necesitamos un decreto ley ni cosas
complicadas Si nos movilizamos todos
para cumplirlo en el peor de los
escenarios pasaremos el invierno Dani le
preguntó que otros detalles se conocen
de este plan de macrón pues mire en el
sector público incluye limitar el agua
caliente en los edificios públicos en la
temporada de invierno reducir la
temperatura de la calefacción también
bajar la intensidad de la iluminación y
reemplazar las lámparas viejas por led
adicionalmente se pidió a los
funcionarios que viajen en tren en lugar
de avión cuando estén a menos de 4 horas
de distancia y que conduzcan a la
velocidad cuando usen vehículos públicos
de todas maneras este es un plan Raúl
que es no es obligatorio por el momento
es opcional en el sector privado también
se han comprometido con medidas
similares por ejemplo los estadios de
fútbol y de rugby han acordado reducir
la iluminación antes y después de los
partidos todo esto ocurre justo cuando
varias estaciones de gasolina del país
están secas y se han armado grandes
filas por cuenta de una huelga en
algunas refinerías de Total energes que
es el principal grupo energético de
Francia y es esta medida Daniela debería
mantenerse así de por vida no de por
vida lo que piensan es reducir un 10% en
estos dos años Así que al final uno dice
sí se puede Claro si se puede y para ser
más amigable con nuestro planeta Dani
Rusia de occidente vamos a cambiar de
información reavivaron su debate sobre
el petróleo como arma política así
después Comencemos por el portavoz del
kremlin Dimitri presscov Quien salió voy
a defender este drástico recorte en la
oferta de crudo que planea hacer la OPEP
más Un día después de que esta alianza
de países exportadores de petróleo
liderados por Arabia Saudita más sus
aliados que están encabezados por Rusia
decidiera entregar dos millones de
barriles menos por día a partir de
noviembre Ese es el mayor recorte desde
2020 y supone alrededor de un 2% de los
100 millones de barriles que consume el
mundo por día la mitad de los cuales
viene de esta OPEP más escuchemos que
dijo Dimitri pesco
los formatos op y OPEP más son
institutos que han conformado
repetidamente sus credenciales como
organizaciones muy responsables que
apoyan la estabilidad del mercado
energético mundial por lo tanto las
decisiones que se han tomado tienen como
objetivo estabilizar el mercado del
petróleo no estamos hablando de
solidaridad con un país en particular ni
nuestro país ni cualquier otro los
mercados estables son de interés para
todos ahí tenemos Raúl entonces la
versión rusa ahora vamos con
estadounidense porque este recorte de
producción se decidió ignorando las
súplicas de la Casa Blanca que se
enfureció con la medida Y es que ellos
dicen que lo que está tratando la OPEP
más es de subir los precios que estaban
en 120 dólares por barril hace tres
meses y hoy están en 90 dólares por
barril escuchamos también la versión de
la Casa Blanca
está claro que la OPEP más está
alineando con Rusia y lo dejaré tal y
como lo acabo de exponer la decisión de
la OPEP de recortar las cuotas de
producciones miope mientras la economía
global está lidiando con el continuo
impacto negativo de la invasión de
Ucrania por parte de Putin si esta
medida de la OPEP tiene un impacto
significativo en los precios será
particularmente en los países de
ingresos bajos y medianos Irán y
cambiamos información porque Hay huelga
de pilotos en hora en una aerolínea de
Alemania Sí señor se ha vuelto
recurrente de las huelgas en las
aerolíneas durante todo este periodo en
Europa esta vez le correspondió a la
aerolínea de bajo costo de lufthansa
eurowings que canceló al menos la mitad
de sus más de 500 vuelos diarios
afectando No solamente la operación en
Alemania sino también en los aeropuertos
de estocolmo de Praga y de mallorca el
sindicato de pilotos dice que le deben
reducir el número máximo de horas de
vuelo y no ha llegado a un acuerdo con
los directivos de las compañías decenas
de miles de pasajeros entonces están
afectados escuchemos también que piensan
ellos
es muy molesto nos levantamos a las 3 de
la mañana porque era un vuelo temprano
es bastante estresante me resulta
imposible que solo un mostrador esté
abierto para información y lufthansa Y
eurowings probablemente lo supieron
durante mucho tiempo
también estoy muy cansada y un poco
molesta Espero que encuentren una
solución para nosotros Dani vamos con
otra información de la que hablamos aquí
hace ya algunos meses el problema que
tuvo Toyota con uno de sus vehículos
eléctricos pues se va a realizar se va a
reiniciar esa producción Bueno entonces
recordemos qué fue lo que pasó hace tres
meses Raúl el productor más grande de
vehículos del mundo tuvo que retirar del
mercado y detener las ventas de su
primer vehículo eléctrico el bz 4x esto
por problemas de seguridad como también
lo hizo Subaru que es propiedad un 20%
de Toyota y que sacó de circulación las
unidades de su modelo solterra que
desarrollaron conjuntamente las dos
marcas con Toyota en su momento esta
empresa Toyota descubrió que en su
modelo eléctrico existía el riesgo de
que con los giros o frenazos bruscos se
aflojara un perno y esto aumentaba las
posibilidades de que las ruedas se
aflojaran ahora dice que puede
garantizar que el problema ya está
solucionado pero le tengo otra
información Raúl es que Toyota también
reconoce esta vez que identificó y
solucionó un problema potencial con las
bolsas de aire en el mismo modelo
algunas de ellas habían sido instaladas
de forma incorrecta y corrían el riesgo
de fallar y causar lesiones me quedaron
ganas de comprar un Toyota uno no la
verdad yo voy más
Mercedes la plata no alcanza
Bueno
un 15% que piensa Elevar su producción
de petróleo Noruega Noruega es uno de
los principales productores de petróleo
del mundo no en la opepa ni en la OPEP
más Pero espera incrementar su
producción porque es que ahora Noruega
se ha vuelto digamos ese apoyo de Europa
que no está recibiendo gas de Rusia está
llegando todo a través de Noruega la
mala noticia es que los petroleros la
industria se va a ver sometida a mayores
impuestos el próximo año según lo ha
planteado hoy el gobierno de Centro
izquierda de este país Dani como siempre
Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica más adelante más
economía Así es le tengo más noticias en
una hora